in five four three two one good morning
everybody salutations konichiwa and
hello to your mom international dude I'm
that your mom right up at Ecole a dude
what's up by me I'm gonna turn off their
podcast because of this hey you know
what I don't know I was looking up
trying to figure out the demographics
for my podcast and I don't know what
people come here for some are really
deep where we talk about serious and
there's other ones where we have Alex
where he's just rapping either way
people like it they doing these little
sixth-grade wraps and [ __ ] dude it's
freestyle and eating mangoes and a
psycho circus [ __ ] recorded the video of
him crushing a [ __ ] can on his head I
saw that I can stop watching a dude like
it's it's it's very satisfying to watch
a [ __ ] a giant man like Alex smash
with a [ __ ] with your hand do tiny
little chicken chicken fingers fingers
like this but then when he crushed it
it's sprayed out liquid all over the
place yeah and then if you watch the
video he smashes his can and immediately
like it's a bit already starts talking
like James Tony what Daniel don't be
Ondi [ __ ] crazy
well Pat it's been a long time dear has
been a while I know what you've been up
to man besides making sound bills do
sourdough bread baby joy the fault you
see the [ __ ] tables this guy man yeah
but why the [ __ ] do you know how to make
self do I don't know I went to my
buddy's house and use like a I got some
sourdough bread starter he's like you
want to make bread and I was like all
right and I made it I was like damn it's
fun as [ __ ] like me I'm a little Baker
now do the Brandon thing ever I was like
why just will make a sourdough bread the
most widest think this guy could do
hello children
today you see them a sanding down a
[ __ ] table table I'm just [ __ ]
bored dude I'm trying to figure I should
the dude [ __ ] make I'm building [ __ ]
making bread
I'll make a pie
okay just make it yeah I'll make a
[ __ ] pipe it's gonna make you to make
a sweet one or a savory one do it
[ __ ] make a pile [ __ ] a [ __ ]
I'm doing the pies
cherry pie potato yeah are you gonna
make a high no for oh I'll make a pie do
makeup yeah I'm making pie that's how
you're gonna make I like apple pie do
some of and then make a savory one make
a chicken pot pie nah come on dude your
shoutouts to our boy alex is spos'n
cooking a lot and every time he sends
photos i'm just like that [ __ ] don't
look that great story is that my
favorite story if you [ __ ] he's
telling us about how you started cooking
a steak or some [ __ ] I googled like do I
have to flip it and he still did it the
only man on earth they couldn't stick
out what side that's like y'all why is
the other side of the steak so great
steak for three hours it's still red on
the one side the lovin is his his
cooking experience nah he's always
sending us food in the group chat
he's like abnormal ass [ __ ] yo guys I
cooked rice today well I made a burger
I'm like Tydfil I was like what I did in
the [ __ ] the patties looking this thing
I know I forgot to respond back to his
photo but it was already past but I'm
what I wanted to say to him on the thing
cuz he cooked the burger and then he
chopped up like raw onions jalapenos I
was like I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] pick
that [ __ ] up your [ __ ] burger right
now he was he was saying that to me we
went to go run and he was like yo the
[ __ ] jalapenos and the onion I put on
my burger let's just slap dude that's
just like you know we just looked at I'm
like alright what the funny [ __ ]
thing is is like I didn't I didn't know
that Bay Area people were so specific
about that phrase because like you know
Sacramento everybody else like you don't
say slap for anything else besides music
you spent you say smacks for food but I
didn't know that people get bad about
that [ __ ] cuz you know
is for everything yeah I was like yeah
[ __ ] slaps and I was like oh maybe
that's like a socal thing or some [ __ ]
like the one thing about Alex that we've
learned is that he does things however
he he what he's dad dude what are you
gonna tell me this is how you really do
it he goes not ask who I'll just do it
this hasn't even figured out how to live
like a normal person did it full lives
heat this full lives in a [ __ ]
matchbox I know
duct tape house house like I feel like
he lives in the house and like the three
little pigs he's like nah mama stay here
listen the straws I like the straws this
will told the funniest story well it's
because right now he you know he lives
in this really shitty ass place and by
the way he's paying like 700 bucks a
month for a [ __ ] room that's not a
room they took a regular room they cut
it in half they got some Chinese
contractor to come in and build this
wall by the way that's not even
connected to the outside walls there's a
gap there's like a two-inch gap in
between each side so you could see your
other roommate and the electricity goes
out and then the the person who owns the
house has the audacity to say hey we're
all in this together dude he was got
like 25 bucks bro I'm trying to get the
power back yeah
you guys wanna chip in he was telling us
that like a couple like a week ago he
was saying oh yeah our sinks don't work
so we have to brush our teeth in the
shower and I was like hey man I don't
know what else to tell you but you have
to get out of this abusive relationship
with your house I know [ __ ] get out
he's mentally [ __ ] he thinks he needs
to yeah and he's like dude those stories
though I'm like nah get the [ __ ] out of
there bro make new stories somewhere
else don't be there at all like the
price for his room I remember we were in
the car he goes knives because it's
cheap that you can't find in any places
out there that are just as cheap I got
on Craigslist two minutes I found like
twelve houses
sounds like same price and an actual
room dude that's the thing about David
though is that you you will you will
find what you pay for for your house and
then find you a better deal immediate he
did that the other day you know what my
hobby is is just to walk around and look
at homes and I can't afford yeah it's my
biggest hobby well we go on walks he's
like oh that house is 1.2 million was
actually sold by the independent dealer
in 1997 but after that and he does that
all forever all the houses have been TIF
is like what about that house and she's
like oh I don't know about that house
she shows the most obscure what I know
he likes this [ __ ] house in the corner
she goes I like that houses liked if I'm
not gonna know anything about it I'm
trying to imagine home that I want to
live in it is a Motorhome what about
that tree right there Keebler Elf spec
is it expensive how much is that home
every single house in South Pasadena is
a house that I will never be able to
afford yes what you say now
2 pi almost break the mike about you but
it's 2.2 million for like a house so
there was this home that I was looking
at that I couldn't afford even if it
wasn't for the price that it sold but it
was like $800,000 right I was looking at
this house super [ __ ] small to
2-bedroom 1-bath and somebody just redid
it two bedroom one bath in the house as
a whole is only a thousand square feet
and it was on market for $850,000 in
South Pasadena on north near Mission
Street which is a really good price
apparently for some [ __ ] reason
yeah and so I looked at it I was like I
got pot before this [ __ ] right just get
me like let me kill a couple of bodies
and fish it out and then a week later it
got sold although somebody bought this
for 850,000 it was sold for 1.2 million
we're a two-bed one-bath damn too bad
one bad you could if you from the front
of the window you could look to the back
of the house how small it is dude dude a
thousand square feet of just the home
that's not that big at all it's not like
South Pasadena is crazy though it's cuz
it's so [ __ ] size but like damn dude
that's insane I dude but you know what
there's places are crazier my buddy went
to school up in San Francisco he went to
college about dude he had a room just a
room no kitchen no bathroom there was
like a community bathroom with the whole
[ __ ] bedroom he's spending he was
renting out for like 1,200 bucks a month
that's following the crazy man my sister
when she was living in San Francisco she
all her she like through two other
roommates and they all had really good
job see I worked for Google like a
Mozilla or whatever and my sister had a
really good job too I think they all
were being paid like over six figures
but they all had to share a [ __ ] home
like with three other people I can't do
that [ __ ] yeah yeah that's how expensive
it is out there it sounds like a
nightmare I would never live would you
rather live in your place right now or a
[ __ ] let's say a mansion in Virginia
man I don't know I think Virginia
racists maybe I don't know
Virginians out there that are listening
to this how races are they out there and
when you get attacked when I get
attacked what'd he get attack I don't
think they'd be able to figure out what
you are first of all yeah they'd be like
what kind of if you just got even the
race bar first is like well let's figure
out what species they would bring back
[ __ ] idiot this guy looks weird as
[ __ ] I don't know what he is yeah I
don't know I know I think I would I
would be able to live in a Virginia in a
mansion in a Virginia yes in a Virginia
so English is not my first language but
I don't think TIF would I don't think
TIF would live out there she because
it's hard for me to picture myself
living out in a place where I just can't
do anything right now like what is there
to do out there I don't know I don't
know I don't know first of all I don't
want to talk [ __ ] about Virginia I was
just gonna say I'm gonna say first of
all I love Virginia so you hate Virginia
continuum oh I love Virginia you guys
the home of the tree grass Virginia I
remember I went there one time to like a
settlement Jamestown for a field trip in
seventh grade
it was it was very nice I just remember
it was very green the airport was very
small so I was right now home of the
cheese it was cool so I went so I went
to a private school for like two years
to private school [ __ ] Nick I'm on
Hot Cheetos and takis over here with
filete McNown oh yeah that's what we had
for lunch every day you know I was on it
there for like a I don't say a
scholarship but it was like oh the
Finance Mart [ __ ] can read Ted it was
financial it was late so [ __ ] cool
dude my rent second rate at time of the
reading so it's [ __ ] up that you
brought that up hooked on phonics saved
my life
were you really wasn't born in this
country huh
so one time too right yeah [ __ ] how
come you don't talk about your ESL
experience why'd you get so weird right
now why I cut you off I wasn't turned
about no no if there was nothing
important about that but it was just all
I was gonna say it was Virginia's very
nice I didn't know you went to a private
school and you could read that's crazy I
can barely read not when I went for like
two years and we went on like a
financial aid thing and it was you know
I never heard it was what's the biggest
difference between private school and
public school dude so when I went to
private school I didn't it was a it was
a Christian school and I didn't know
anything about the Bible
I didn't know who Jesus Christ was I
didn't know anything go ahead now and
okay
and when I went there the kids would
like ask me like hey have you accepted
Jesus Christ as Lord and Savior and I
looked at him I was like what I was like
no no I believe in Buddha I'm a nation
if no God doesn't have a fat belly and
some big earrings I don't give a [ __ ]
and that's what I said to them dude my
marrow but they were like trying to tell
me like oh yeah you know if you accept
Jesus as your Lord and Savior
when you die you get to go to heaven and
you can have whatever you want and you
want to look and you were like well
guess what when I [ __ ] die come back
as a butterfly I'd rather be a verified
thank you and I just it was I had no
idea what's going on Middle School's
rough I didn't really like it at all it
was uh
you were some middle school you're like
10 right 11 you didn't know Jesus Christ
I dude I didn't know anything I didn't
want everybody knows that my family my
family wasn't religious at all but like
you walk outside you see you know
pictures of the dog the stood in the
window
I pledge allegiance fifth from fifth
grade all the plastics for the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation one
nation under God is Christ in invisible
to the indivisible to the to the Death
Eaters in the ball the more we got it
under God under God you know God was
know right yeah I just didn't know what
Jesus who Jesus was
I didn't I remember when you people say
like Jesus Christ yeah you didn't hear
that and then I will
would never say I would I didn't say
that I don't think I did not until I was
in that school I would say Jesus Christ
all the time and I would get in trouble
there saying his name in vain I would
say Jesus Christ and then they would get
mad at me and I was like you guys say it
all the time but weird like I like I did
confirmation classes for Catholicism the
weirdest [ __ ] all private school
kids everyone was weird everybody was so
light and weird in class but they were
like the weirdest [ __ ] kids what is
not a confirmation class so Catholicism
you have to there's three stages right
you do your communion that's when you
eat like the little the little chip a
body is a body of bits that's it by the
way is naseous what the wine was chilled
though I was a little kid I just wine
but he's not so way no the first step is
baptism that's when like you're a baby
they don't you jeopardized I did I got
baptized oh she's been baptized gonna
pop that communion is the second one and
then confirmations the last one but I
did it late but you have to like do
classes and like [ __ ] like I had to
go on a retreat with a bunch of weirdos
and on a mountain and like some lady
washed my feet it was just weird like I
didn't we did this drill we're like we
shook hands right and like we would do
this like they would tell some people to
do this I don't write and they were like
if you get the little scratchy scratch
you have to start doing the scratchy
scratch to people to wait what does that
mean we did this as like there's like 50
kids in this cabin doing this and at the
end of it and they were like oh this is
what aids represents this is how fast
you can get eight because everyone was
scratching it and oh my and I was just
like that's well like wait I want to go
home God that really happened we watched
a walk to remember anymore many more
that was like that movie a dancer oh
dude spoiler yeah sorry I love her yeah
we just watched that and they were like
aids this is love like this is like a
show the movie to like represent what la
this is what I [ __ ] hated sometimes
like listen I grew up in a Christian
household I was a youth
for a couple of years oh really yeah a
couple years you know that I have my
father's a pastor I was a youth minister
for a little bit and I just didn't know
too much about the Kubelik religion yeah
what I hated about a lot of churches
that they would do that [ __ ] they would
make you do all these random activities
right and they go boom
aids [ __ ] man you do that no aids I
would do [ __ ] like this in like
Christian churches right so we would go
out on these retreats and they would
always have a guest speaker right
sometimes the guest speakers like a
really prolific speaker at another
church and he comes and he gives like
this dope sermon or whatever however
other times depending on the type of
kids that you have in your congregation
they would get a random thug to come in
I didn't sign up for him but this guy
just comes in and he's just standing up
there just mean-mugging us just tatted
up as [ __ ] I'm like well this pastor
looks weird he comes in he goes yeah I
used to be like you yeah I think I was
tough I used to be a [ __ ] sinner like
hey bro
try that the cursor scared straight I
used to be a [ __ ] sinner yeah but I
changed my life because of Jesus Christ
and if you gonna let him heal me he
gonna heal you - I'll do drugs more I
was like bro nobody does drugs yeah yeah
the wrong peanut the Jesus Christ guy
and then you have our weird Korean
pastor come out you see that yes that's
the way the Jesus Christ the way he
thought he said hand David look big
piece of [ __ ] I got this one this is say
he could save him he explains a lot
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
poppin off yeah at that time so what
you'd have sex right that's the thing is
scare you but they probably realize at
least when I was there that like just
saying don't have sex is not like a
people gonna have sex that's ridiculous
so they're like we'll just scare the
share these kids aids uncomfortable hate
that [ __ ] cuz all that little like the
little cholo dudes Isis go to school
with they would always like [ __ ] with
you and like do that to your hand
they give me aids and I do know that
like that was the thing that was good
policy ISM that's crazy I never knew
where this develop associated this it's
always brown homies - it's always like
the little children that for dude yeah
dude [ __ ] all that [ __ ] there was like
like we had to do like an hour-long
meditation in this cabin they put like
these shrines up in the middle and there
was like a circle of people and there
was like weird they put like this little
shitty stereo like oh like that Maria
type music that's tired and like there's
just like the adults are like bowing and
like crying and we had to do like pray
to this shrine for an hour and like
people around me are crying like crying
bawling the kids are crying like [ __ ]
doing the [ __ ] this and I'm sitting
there like I don't feel anything right
yeah I felt like I was a [ __ ] like I
was Satan worshippers that's how I would
feel - when I was going on the Christian
school and it was like the best things I
had the experience was like the chapel's
cuz they'd have a speaker come in and
they'd always relate like cool stories
with faith and I was like oh that's dope
I like I like that but everything else I
just felt like I was faking the funk the
whole time yeah I had no idea what that
wasn't
- man yeah and then it also seems like
all the homies that grew up Catholic it
just seems like a lot of work like to go
like it you always have events to go to
the the prayers are super long well
people go clears it's the
hyper-intelligent is something theythey
really enjoyed though like they
definitely got something out of it I
think the weird part is when you don't
know what's going on that you gotta have
to go along with the motion yeah yeah
did you guys did you ever had this
experience where people were speaking in
tongues around you
no I never got that you let me tell you
that shit's [ __ ] yeah like there's a
couple of situations so my parents would
speak in tongues right which I guarantee
hell yeah I shouldn't do not know how to
do that [ __ ] but this [ __ ] was just
going along I kid you not so my parents
used to have these things called Kooyong
yabba's right and this is like a it's a
gathering like this religious gathering
thing where people come and pray
together they would share food share
stories have good lasts and make
basically it's aside from praise it's
just to reconnect with your with your
friends so but at the end at like 12
o'clock at midnight everybody would
start speaking in tongue now speaking
and tongue is supposed to be a gift from
God right so it's it's a puzzle if
there's a demon thing or something no
that's the other thing is the Holy
Spirit exercise was taken over by the
Holy Spirit and then you're actually
there was a somebody who recorded
somebody speaking in tongue once right
I'm not this not to freak anybody out
but there was a person who recorded how
many different languages that person was
speaking and it was like 30 languages
which was so [ __ ] weird right so I
was supposed to be like the Holy
Spirit's taking you over you don't know
what you're saying but it's like the
Word of God or some [ __ ] like that's
crazy
and so I guarantee you that in this room
this this this gift that very few people
in this world have there's suddenly 12
Korean old [ __ ] are gonna know how to
do it right and so they would meet up
they would dim the lights they would
play this Korean Christian music in the
background and everybody would be
speaking in tongue and then my mom would
do that too and I would just look at my
mom like [ __ ] you don't know how to do
this for a fact I legit saw my mom once
just go Bob opener I like
that's really what it looks like with
somebody speaking tug because I saw a
video somebody speaking tongue right and
I was like that looks kind of real huh
what my mom was doing was not real no
this [ __ ] was just going with the flow
she's like is this how you do it she
would look at them move their tongue as
she goes okay but they would do that
stuff all the time and when I was in
college there was this group called que
si si si si Korean Christian Crusaders
for Christ's okay Triple C right a
[ __ ] weird-ass group and really by the
name yes but they were hyper hyper
religious and so
you know I I was a Christian kid - okay
let me see what these guys are about
long story short I remember on Fridays
they would do this thing called
gethsemane and guess Emma days in
reference to something in the Bible it's
like a mountain or something like that I
could be completely wrong I'm finding a
lot of questions right now like pastor
my ass drop the Bible into a ball so
what happened was right this is little
guy that has a ring and it has a lot of
power okay everybody's like Lord of the
Rings to me right and this guy he's not
Jesus Christ but we call him Dumbledore
Dumbledore Dumbledore right Dumbledore
and you can't say his name no no
everything up right and then when the
death star comes in but this place
called gethsemane and everybody would do
the whole praying in tongues right now
as a young person I would see these
adults do it and I'm like for sure you
[ __ ] aren't speaking in tongue
right but now that you have these older
people doing it they're convincing these
younger kids that if they just let Jesus
into their lives they could start
speaking tongue as well so I remember
there's this Korean FOP kid this Fabia's
kid and everybody's praying they're
crying they're doing the whole thing
worship music scone on people are
feeling things I'm standing there like I
don't feel here I'm going to hell yeah
that's what I felt I felt like I'm going
to help because everybody feels it but
me right but I think I was just being
honest right yeah and so that guy comes
over to me
I'm kidding you not goes hey can I pray
for you that's a Korea Bobby that can I
pray for you I was like cool this pray
he goes let's get on our knees right and
I'm like okay is like well I want you
know I I feel like Jesus Christ can you
know get on this together and knees and
pray and I'm like well I'm going to hell
anyway this is my last ticket let me
just try to [ __ ] out so I get on my
knees
this [ __ ] grabs me right I'm
talking about by the side of my face is
right and he starts just a fan bidding
in my face and I'm mortal
I'm scared you weren't expecting that I
didn't expect him to grab me and start
speaking in tongues and start spitting
in my face and I'm just like what the
[ __ ] and look at my friend Daniel and
he's Daniel was my roommate he's the guy
that was super into Casey so you see at
the time he said when that brought me in
uh huh he said this suppose I pray he
looks over and looks at me and he just
goes watch either he does this to me I
can't remember it said it felt like half
an hour but he just did the whole prayer
all the way through it I just sit there
was spit in my face Jesus so he's saying
a specific prayer I don't know what he
was saying he was speaking in tongues he
didn't ramp up into it he just went oh
no he 0 to 100 there was no like dear
the Lord father God I want to thank you
had to understand when I got my it was
just we started making out it got really
[ __ ] weird penis taste this one okay
this one I went to uh I went to a
funeral and it was a it was like a
Catholic saw funeral and I guess they
say at the at the end of it they do like
the rosary I don't know what it is but
if they do like a prayer and they do it
like I don't know how many times but it
was way more than one time it was like
20 times they say the same thing over
and over again and it's in Spanish and
they're standing up and down the whole
time and I'm just [ __ ] I don't dude I
don't know what the [ __ ] was going on
and the whole time I'm just like sing
back up looking around yeah and and you
I have to like repeat everyone saying
the same thing over and over again and
I'm the only [ __ ] chinito in the whole
[ __ ] building
and I'm tip is sitting next to me just
laughing because she knows that are you
talking about the sitting up and down
words in front and there's like the
little knee thing right you got a kneel
you understand we didn't do we were just
sitting down in a chair in chairs and
everybody was saying the prayers over
and over again there was a Spanish and
then something something about the fruit
of Christ has the only thing I got fruit
that they hiss ooh and then I just was
like I was for you now how do you know
what sucks is that sometimes because
they'll sing songs right and some people
know all the words like they're [ __ ]
like they're not battling in [ __ ] they
know all this all the lyrics and like
but sometimes like they'll finish a song
with like it'll be like Amen right
they'll be like oh man
but sometimes they trick you and they do
like a like a remix ah men they'll be
like oh they don't tell you when that
shit's coming so like I'm trying to
participate and I'll be like man and be
what dumb as [ __ ] on purpose they do
that [ __ ] on purpose just like they want
to see you slippin they want to see what
you said there was the the baptism part
that was what else the communion is the
middle and then the confirmation that's
the last part where you like have to get
a sponsor you feel like you have to go
to classes you could get a sponsor
somebody that's a good confirmed
Catholic I think you're dissing a a do
some bishop comes yeah I know right
some [ __ ] like Cardinal or something
from the state they have like select
leaders of regions comes and like says
that you're these guys are [ __ ] crazy
but really because they're just
molesting the whole [ __ ] country yeah
yeah that's the other that's 100 that's
when you're really how [ __ ] dare you
speak about you hop that have you ever
seen a witch call it the there was a net
it was a documentary on Netflix and it
was called it was about all the the
Catholic priests I forgot what it was
called the rape of the children it might
as well have been doing right but they
don't like this dude like this but he
would this guy this is one of the
priests that they followed he would tell
his his is like 12 year olds whatever
like
yeah get on your knees and you're gonna
swallow the Holy Spirit yeah there you
go and he would just Dan that is a cold
[ __ ] I don't have to say
anything more cuz you already know what
that means and he would do it's just
like a rap diss battle how did he do
that to the key really you're gonna
swallow the holiness spirit from the
Vatican but no like and it was like
unforgivable I forgot what a carbonara
the carbonara
yeah make this painful after at this
point cuz that's so sad yeah but it was
it's uh yeah just go watch if you guys
want to you know feel sad a [ __ ] you
want to be a very upset
yeah go watch that documentary because
it's uh it's it's good and maybe it's
there so many movies based on the
Catholic the raping like you've
explained nothing about the documentary
I forgot what it's called in three words
but that's as far as I got
he wanted to say the thing about the
Holy Spirit he wanted to say that but he
had no structure to that verse the
keeper's that the name of the
documentary okay I got that that's one
out of a thousand facts of the
documentary but it's [ __ ] really sad
so just watch it great people that are
listening right now is like where the
[ __ ] is this conversation leading do you
have any stories based you know you know
people like you you know what I used to
do after you were done talking I [ __ ]
I would get my phone right I would open
up Google Maps and say where are you
going with this let me show you show me
where you're going with this I was just
waiting for you guys to swoop in cuz
David always has a million facts that he
says what about I don't know about
children any [ __ ] be buddies movies
based on that you ever seen a movie
spotlight no why don't you watch yeah
you're a bunch of rape CAD amia war dude
for best power give a [ __ ] you're over
below he was holed out yeah he was a
it's a anyways it's how it's based about
right they uncover we're finding out his
luck at hobbies
he's sweating so much just I just like
what's going on you guys you guys watch
this other cartoon or just kick car to
Nick what are you talking about then I
just I just watch too much sounds to
kick it fondling stuff yeah I don't know
I like I like when that one's justice is
served
I mean fighting a lot it's hot in here
jean-claude van Damme dude you're
[ __ ] about to go to a cooler right
now why it's the summertime when
summertime comes out I look like JC BD
babe I do some between big rigs and
jean-claude Van Damme playing guile from
Street Fighter was the weirdest thing
ah the best dude I so watch that movie
Fame and everyday it I love that movie
dude when I was a kid blonde like a
homeless guy they just covered himself
in paint he was like a Mexican Brazil
you [ __ ] was a Mexican music racist I
had races by you went to a Catholic
Church you didn't learn anything oh you
went to a Catholic Christian rape school
I got I got in trouble a lot over there
and I never you know it was a bad time
in my life
Wow okay wait you said justice is served
how was justice served at the in the
Catholic Church because I heard that's
just still going oh yeah you know but
it's just you know the fact that people
are making documentaries about it I
appreciate that and then the movie about
spotlight the spots they uncovered they
uncovered the scandals because they were
moving priests all across the East Coast
and then the movie spotlight is about
how this these land it land the point
this nowhere to land there's nowhere to
land some are flying like one of the
turbines exploded don't [ __ ] it wing
fell off
I'm gonna pull it dip it upside down
that's what I was gonna refer I forgot
the name of that movie too
but um yeah spotlights a good movie yes
you go watch that just picture this this
Italian Pope - super mad at you hey Nick
I shut up about the documentary yeah
yeah but people know about it so people
understand that about Catholic Church
that like they're out there just
molesting kids and raping kids right I
always thought that concept was so odd
right because within what can well
obviously rape is a very hard thing in
general but you don't you don't allow
you don't allow them to have sex with
women but then [ __ ] you you couldn't
like literally just blaspheme and
destroy these people for having sex with
the opposite sex or the same sex but
then [ __ ] this kid is like a menace
okay am i above yeah we'll move you to
the other color I don't understand the
logic behind that like how did they
somehow that just goes to show you
should have sex like you should be
looking insane the logic doesn't [ __ ]
make sense to me at all no not at all
this just shows a kid I was like wait
when my mom she told me I was young she
was like priests can't have sex and I
was like I was like eight at the time
but I still was like what and they
volunteered what's the [ __ ] yeah
patty about sex when you're eight or
eight years old I knew about sex when I
was young I says that's a sexual
maverick I think for at all but I used a
vanilla thought I had a some like some
Latino dude came over and like put in
like the legal box like do you remember
those like had people box baby and you
like give him a little money under the
table and he'd like bounce out but
channel 41 was the spice Channel I
wasn't supposed to go to him I was like
don't go to channel 41 like ever so
obviously when she was out of house
channel 41 of course click channel 41
softcore porn dude in the shower naked
people saw more porn was so weird
it is weird they're just like we get to
see anything except for titties it's
like you know fascinates me is like how
do they shoot it like you know like
that's that's such a weird thing for the
actors to do like they're just coming
you they might as well just have sex
yeah you might as well as well I just
crying you guys are naked as [ __ ] and
you guys are just grinding up on each
other you guys Myles was just bone
nobody would know the difference you
know that's what would always go through
my head
watch it am i right you guys big
softcore porn fancies would always show
me the good channels what were you
saying channel 4 he told me start you
watch porn from your dad because I mean
it was just okay why did you watch porno
funny weird all right dude see he just
[ __ ] you put me on the spot do it to
me the hot seat so when I was a kid when
I was probably like fifth grade I found
out what what skinemax was and the
late-night HBO channels so what did you
have the illegal [ __ ] or the real [ __ ]
we had I think we had the was on charter
this is a long time private school and
he had read so much about [ __ ] suck I
do suck you're one of those kids with
the [ __ ] real toys huh yeah I guess
yeah I will get the knockoff toys you
get the liquor store that's made out of
the real tool now we would get like the
knockoff toys from like Chinatown like
the [ __ ] little like the Power
Rangers aren't real parents were around
and bought you toys huh Game Boy Color
oh yeah balanced game boys I would get
hand-me-downs from my sisters I play
with their Barbies I play with their
stuff you had healthy sisters man yeah
sisters well thanks and so like my my
mom my parents would always like watch
the TV in the living room and then I
would go in my dad's room and he had a
the cable box in there and he would be
asleep so I would go and he was a heavy
sleeper and I would do this all the time
all the time and I would eventually one
time he caught me and I was watching
obviously softcore porn and I just hear
my dad said turn it off and I'm like and
I just ran out the [ __ ] room like
just freaking the [ __ ] out with your dad
what was your dad was it was sleeping on
the couch no no he was in his bed he was
sleeping he was sleeping he was a heavy
sleeper and then I just heard him and I
turned on the TV and I obviously
realized he probably knew I was doing
that for a while I probably watching it
behind you like and he just was like
this in his bed just like good [ __ ]
turned out but and then eventually he
was like hey turn it off and I was like
all right and I just [ __ ] I don't
even think I
do that if I was your dad right and I
saw my kid watching porn at that age I
would flip on the lights and laugh my
ass yeah exacto [ __ ] hard dude my dad
was surprised he was very uncomfortable
about that stuff I remember okay this is
if he would wake up in the morning and
his pancakes would be the shape of a
[Laughter]
cloud on this fool for the longest time
to scar him mentally what Dad I don't
watch porn sure you don't its own so my
junior in high school oh yeah you like
that oh yeah yeah dad stop I remember we
were in it was like on spring break or
something I went to San Diego with my
parents and my I guess my mom was like a
CBS and we were waiting it for her to
come back out and I'm sitting in the
back seat of the van and my dad just
goes junior year in high school he goes
hey Nick you like you you talk to girls
right and I'm like what what are you
what are you talking about he's like
like you're like dating girls and stuff
right that's cool
and I'm like dad what are you yeah yeah
I talk to girls like whatever like i was
super-embarrassed but he was literally
asking like hey like you into girls
that's what he was [ __ ] ask you again
and he was worried that I wasn't talking
to girls yeah he saw your address he's
okay she's like thank you you saw me
watching porn all right you do you know
I'd like I liked it you know me I dad I
like I like the ass slapping I like I
like girls I like girls I do I swear I
would ask my son if he was gay or not
just to figure it out it's like say
[ __ ] for me it's it's how you said it
so it's okay I probably feel all those
tests yeah if you like an Italian -
Billy come on man I like it up boys yeah
percent Korean yeah saying you know I'd
be like straight I like it the booze I
wonder how I would feel I don't know if
I would feel a certain way if my kid was
gay but it'd be so interesting cuz I
don't know any a family members that are
gay so you don't have any gay family
members not that I know of so maybe
they're not they didn't come out or
something like that but I don't
as of now that I know if I don't have
any gay family members so that would be
the first little homo in our family and
I'd be awesome look at you dude I love
you so much you're Trailblazer love it
I'm pretty sure by the time we have kids
the whole gay thing I mean it's kind of
Pat that's already like yeah California
anyways yeah I don't like yeah if
somebody comes out if my kids like hey
dad I just want to let you know I'm gay
it's like I've been knowing full yeah
[ __ ] nobody eat hot dogs no tacos we all
know tacos taste way better keep on
going for the hot and the way we're dude
you try to put them in your asses under
table as I said it you swallow all your
hot dogs like you know daddy still loves
you come on now and [ __ ] weirdo I
think it's weird that you interrupted me
to [ __ ] let me know this [ __ ] alright
that no world that I want to live in
yeah if my son was gay I wouldn't own
care I may have a daughter if she's
lesbian I would be like even that'd be
dope yeah let me tell you what ladies
like dad know we'll go down down down
you all came out from dead daddy also
went in there to talk about gay I mean I
thought you were gay dude I don't know
what is it chances were I think you just
he wanted to make sure that I was like
talking to girls were you wearing this
tank top when you were talking I was I
was wearing a different color of this
was thrown off you know in retrospect
looking back on my high school years I
would understand why he asked me that
and why he thought like you know did you
have what what we considered back then
as day tendencies I don't know a man
probably probably yeah
oh yeah what did you do I don't know but
but I remember it was only one other
person that asked me if I was gay once
and I was like that and I was like cuz I
mean I think I did a lot of I think I'm
more in touch with my feminine feminine
yeah right cuz I like ooh you know my
parents had a beauty supply store I
stuck around there a lot so I'd be
braiding [ __ ] here shamelessly I used
to braid her hair and [ __ ] algebra I
was bored out of my [ __ ] mind
she had this long silky hair and that's
like can i braid your hair [ __ ]
every algebra class you like thanks Dave
and I got you boo next who next yeah cuz
I grew up with mostly women in my life
you know so it's like I'm yeah oh yeah
you have you probably more in touch with
your face yeah and yeah yeah I think so
that's just me dude and in high school I
had more I had more girlfriends than I
did guy friends to me like a loser
until I wonder if the whole coming out
thing I mean cuz I had a friend on this
podcast and she was talking about her
coming-out situation I wonder how
different it is going to be for a lot of
these kids now is like the coming-out
thing gonna be a big thing or is it just
gonna be like oh you're gay or you wanna
be well-liked at least in California I
think it's gonna be like normal like yep
yes probably sooner to rather than later
because I know a lot of people they come
out like later in their lives you know
but I think it's probably gonna be
sooner where people come out and they're
more comfortable that because it's
probably more of a normal thing anyway
because it's normalizes everyone
everywhere TV you seen in movies right
it's it's it's portrayed Eliza it's a
weird thing when I see people who care
so much whether somebody else is gay or
not it's a very odd he does that all the
time
bigots it's like a weird thing when
people get angry about it right yeah
like I don't you know what it makes no
sense
yeah cuz why not you know I grew up as a
Christian I never care you know it's
like cool cool story it was it was I
never could wrap my head around that too
and I remember when there was the whole
thing when we were going whether gay
people was a gay people can get married
or not right yeah and somebody was
asking my opinion about it and you know
cuz they knew my father was a pastor
yeah and now it's I don't care yeah who
the [ __ ] cares they tell me get married
don't get [ __ ]
who cares yeah just of course like a see
you later come on what's crazy is that
like they're they'll be like you could
be at a restaurant that could be a gay
couple and you're like you guys are
eating or whatever and there's a gay
couple over there and then at there's
another table of some people that are
eating and they look open they're like
what the [ __ ] how [ __ ] dare you
like that's disgusting like Mike Pence
doesn't he like isn't he's super against
gay marriage and things like that I
don't know I didn't go to like a
conversion thing like more like a gay I
think yeah I think he started it and he
would like he thought electrotherapy
worked for for to fix gay people to fix
gay people yeah that was like his stance
that's why everyone made fun of him
about that [ __ ] that's hilarious like
I'm going joke about it that is [ __ ]
hilarious is that crazy yeah they're
like oh you're the vice president the
world in husband nation of the world of
the nation of the woman so there's this
girl named Lindsay and I remember she
she was one of those people that was
super gung-ho for like gay rights and
[ __ ] right which I at the time in high
school didn't know gay people didn't
have certain rights yeah you know I mean
I didn't know this [ __ ] [ __ ] no no
you guys couldn't get married I thought
anybody could get married I thought you
could get married to a [ __ ] dolphin
if you wanted to shout out to my
Japanese people no they get ready to
anything out there but really dude
there's a guy that got married to his
like game or some [ __ ] it was like a
girl that he created in a game and he
got married to that girl Japanese people
are doing [ __ ] dude all his assets go to
her when he died I have no [ __ ] idea
you know in Japan they also have
something called [ __ ] bars oh I heard
about that yeah you sit at a table you
have a beer and somebody sucks your dick
yeah Wow or you can eat food too
yeah you just be eating a steak it's so
much how many people are just gonna eat
steak was like what are you good more
focus on the steak or the [ __ ] in
nobody finish the dinner
always a leftover food
you see a [ __ ] steak with a knife in
it and that's it where they started how
would you not laugh like looking down
the bar seeing people nut yeah it's just
the Wednesday but there's like weird
[ __ ] marbles sure let's talk about
people getting
Gameboys or some [ __ ] but also [ __ ]
[ __ ] bars that's that's like that's
cool they should do that I have a
massage massage like sexual massages too
when they get oiled up and they start
rubbing all up on you and [ __ ] - I like
that technique right there's only the
bottom of the wrist - they don't write
back and it's the bottom of the [ __ ]
wrist I read about the a [ __ ] bar
thing from a maxim magazine or some kind
of magazine where they were talking
about like they interviewed like a sex
worker or something like that and they
interviewed this Japanese girl where she
was talking about these these the places
where you can get we call them
prostitution places or whatever Bravo
let me ask you there you go thanks Nick
you know these brothels and apparently
like in Japan there's certain spots that
they allow foreigners to go and a lot of
spots they don't allow if you're not
like a Japanese citizen they won't elect
you to come in crazy
so like [ __ ] bars - are one of those
things were exclusively like Japanese
people or some [ __ ] like person being
jack and it was funny too cuz like when
I was reading the article the the
journalist was asking some [ __ ] weird
questions like one of the questions was
are Japanese men's penises large they
got they're different and very sizes
sums are so big it hurts sometimes it's
very small like this is a professional
dirty hook wow this is really really
[ __ ] cool but back to that girl
Lindsay she was so mad at me and she's
super gung-ho about shoes so she got mad
at me because I remember she was asking
me what to do yeah I pulled the Nick
done that I like that like that yeah so
playing the Catholic churches so she was
saying to me because she knew that my
father was a pastor and I wasn't
Christian kids she goes she looks at me
and she just goes you need to be more
tolerant and I was like what it came out
of nowhere I remember this day after
school because I was so irritated at her
being I don't know what she was talking
about she goes
gay people deserve to get married too
and I was like yeah I'm gonna get
married I didn't write it right and she
goes she goes you should be more
tolerant and I'm like of what what does
that mean [ __ ] I'm dumb as [ __ ] yeah
what are you understand be tolerant like
gay people should have rights I was like
yeah no [ __ ] what are you saying right
now here is she would go around and she
would attack anybody who was like
Christian she was so upset
I was like what are you saying I don't
know these things I don't was going on
like she assumed that I knew that gay
people couldn't get married and nothing
well that's not cool there was it there
was a gay dude at my high school - that
was kind of like that but he would just
be like you look like [ __ ] straight
people like you in the hallways like he
[ __ ] straight boys like straight people
piss me off like that it's like what the
[ __ ] dude like that's you're making
people dislike you yeah yeah I mean
that's not you like make friends dude
that's how it is in high school though
right like kids get so [ __ ] put in
their box and they believe that's like
the only way to look at everything and
high school just everybody kids man
there was just other dude his name was
Nathan I actually knew this kid from my
previous elementary school before the
one that got removed from it was water
stabbing someone in the face yeah I
think yeah let's move on from that
this kid Nathan very interesting kid he
actually moved to Alaska not too long
ago and he became a pastor but I
remember this kid because he was
suffering from depression now I didn't
know what depression was I just thought
it was sadness yeah okay but I remember
he just kept talking about his
depression to everybody right which I
know it's go for a walk I don't have a
[ __ ] this kid was so [ __ ] weird
because he would tell everybody about
his depression all the time and I just
remembered looking into his ear cavity
and it had earwax just coming out I was
like maybe you're depressed because you
can't hear anything yeah start with that
no but I sick burn that's a good burn
but as I was talking to me about
depression I didn't know about [ __ ]
depression and he goes and we started
getting into a little argument because
he kept on trying to talk me about the
[ __ ] and mind you I was really nice too
because I remember him from elementary
school so I want to saw him in high
school I was like I remember he's at the
elementary weird kid right and I think
we were friends as elementary students
but he became a little weird and he was
just talking about his depression to
everybody I remember at one time I just
looked at him he just goes he goes David
like I'm just so depressed as I bro I
don't give a [ __ ] got so irritated and I
was like go do something about it right
and then he looks at me hey mind you I'm
a lot older than you
he didn't know about depression it
wasn't a huge time reminisce and he
looks at me and he goes he goes it's a
chemical imbalance and I remember I
looked at him and I was like you're a
[ __ ] loser and I just walked away
yeah and I look back at it now I'm like
David that was a very terrible way to
handle this [ __ ] but at the time it's
like I don't know it was he was this
just shows how mean kids can be in high
school and how they can make a change it
was that or exactly yeah myself my
recipe statement he's out in Alaska he's
a pastor he had a wife he has a kid he's
good he actually moved to another state
because of me no but he I think I think
he kind of leveled himself out the
problem was like in high school there
was a lot of guys I guess during that
time whatever they found it was like
that emo Rock stage you know people were
all getting to their feelings and I
think everybody has that during high
school because now we have email rap so
during my time it was emo Rock and so
they listen to this music at all all up
in there [ __ ] feeling start writing
poetry and poems but there was the other
like a bunch of losers expressing their
feelings right and all right guys yeah
yeah yeah and so we've been there we've
all been there and that's probably why
your dad asked you that question I
remember there's this other kid his name
was Jeremy and the reason why I couldn't
take like the pressure seriously because
there was a certain amount of group of
kids that kind of and there's always
people like this that takes something
that's very serious and they try to use
it for their advantage and that's kids
in high school dude kids that should all
yeah yeah so there was this kid you
would always call people's Bluffs this
kid Jeremy he would try to use a
depression thing to get girls to talk to
him just to be like oh are you okay are
you fine and he would like talk to them
after school so I remember one time now
mind you I didn't handle this very well
either cuz I was already fed up with
this because Nathan there talked to me
about his depression for weeks and I had
this other kid named Jeremy and a lot of
the girls were getting irritated of him
because he would hop from
girls within the group because a girl
would catch on like oh he's just using
this so he could talk to me so I could
be his girlfriend they would cut him out
then he'd go to another one then another
one Dan and so I were good so I did not
handle the situation very well either if
it was very serious
I did not do this very well at all
because this kid finally it got to my
ears that he was quote-unquote depressed
and I remember he wrote on AIM as a
group chat he just goes you know what
guys I'm just gonna go and drink bleach
and I was like cool do it school do it I
got so [ __ ] fed up with that [ __ ]
he's rest in peace Jeremy now he's alive
but he would always use that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that guy that guy's a schemer yeah this
guy I think that's fine we had responses
good we knew kids that did the same [ __ ]
too and a lot of it it was like we knew
this one kid who no one [ __ ] liked
and he would like call homies and be
like I'm gonna do it tonight dude I'm
looking like he would yeah we knew he
was never gonna do it cuz he just was
that kind of kid where he was just [ __ ]
and whine about everything and no one
liked him for obvious reasons cuz he
just was like a [ __ ] and he all he
would do is just talk about how he was
gonna [ __ ] you know do the deed but he
never did it but I think he's safe and
that's that's what we said it was so
[ __ ] annoying because there's you
know you take something very serious and
you try to use it for your advantage
it's like those guys that that talk
about like oh man you should I hate when
these [ __ ] dudes or disrespecting
women bla bla bla the white knight [ __ ]
and then right through biggest scumbag
on a hundred percent I [ __ ] hate those
guys and that's what that reminded me of
if you're a guy and you can't you've
never been like damn [ __ ] or annoying
I don't trust you like if you've never
thought that or felt that a little bit
yeah I can't trust you I don't show
you're dishonest as [ __ ] come on that
way and I should hate that because
that's the same like in the opposite of
course girls get [ __ ] annoyed and men
although of course goes both ways men
are all the same yeah the same should we
say the same [ __ ] it's all that it is
exactly and just be honest about it
don't be fake don't try to [ __ ] you
know any mean like that that to give
somebody a free pass for just because
they're a girl or a guy like it's just
like I feel like all those guys talk
illegal uh like they all make that noise
but they all talk like
there's a bunch of people like that so
one time I talked about this on a
previous podcast back in the day where
basically long story short it was like
this video where I called a bunch of
women floozies but the the joke was
they're not floozies it's just that I
can't get women so that's the joke is
that I'm just gonna make fun of girls
because I'm the loser right a joke is
making fun of me cuz the girls look just
like normal girls so obviously they're
not so floozies a funny word dumb word
ever right bunches like your ass you're
a hussy like that but the girl to the
wrong way and that she was like men are
you gonna women are you gonna let this
this man talk about us that way she was
trying to make it a gender yeah and a
bunch of guys jumped on that thing
they're like I hate men like this men
like this are dogs I'm like bro she's
not gonna [ __ ] you dude yeah yeah for
real and I'm fast forward after she made
a big scene about that this [ __ ] it's
the story of her [ __ ] taking off her
top and putting champagne I thought you
were a regular girl you're over here
she's like literally squeezing her tits
and pouring champagne down her [ __ ]
throat come on we're the foot bro for
sex women I was like it's December and
she's literally like [ __ ] pop into the
[ __ ] penis or slapping her ass and
dudes are slapping her ass and I'm like
wait champagne though yeah you can live
your life frozen but I'm saying like if
you were to make an argument that's
probably not the best way yeah that's
yeah some might call you a fancy for
doing that but nobody would call you
Suzie cuz if you want to be a floozy
okay baby my babies - yeah these two
people are just really sensitive like
any little thing like like you make it
it's a [ __ ] joke
I just wanna find a fall right landed
they want to just people want to get
upset over [ __ ] like they just really
want to be outraged because there's like
no they feel like it's important they
feel like they they're doing something
like yeah I'm mad about this people know
that I'm mad about this and I matter you
know it's like like people protesting
about the coronavirus shutdowns like all
that [ __ ]
people are getting there people are like
in Huntington Beach people go out there
and they're protesting all [ __ ]
dancers get in the last a protest in one
day and they're like it's kind of hot
out
yeah it's dude and it's like I'm getting
sick like what do you think this is
right you think you think we want to be
on lockdown [ __ ] where
the they're gonna start opening up
hospitality starting tomorrow right
no not hospitai think like retail like
clothes mmm there's like certain I think
the third phase is when like restaurants
and [ __ ] like that are gonna start
second phase is okay and then it's
curbside pickup though right yeah it's
all like super limited right it's like
super lean yeah
but the third phase is when like gyms
restaurants I think bar [ __ ] like that
and you're gonna be a tough move man
honestly I think I think we're probably
go back in quarantine
we might people open back up again
they're the people gonna get it again
well there's a second everywhere there's
a second wave so I mean I think that's
gonna be inevitable if we don't have
that that's kind of crazy because you
know whatever Singapore do Taiwan is the
only one that's like untouched
oh they got that [ __ ] down pat throw bay
they only had 400 cases
damn not crazy that's crazy and they
haven't had a new one I don't think in a
while I could be wrong because anybody
like corona they just killed him took
him out but they were on they were on
top of his since last year apparently
like they were mass producing everything
and they were like checking everybody
they weren't [ __ ] around they took us
seriously nobody else did
obviously Bill Gates wants to take over
the world yeah what's up with the Bill
Gates stuff I don't know people say his
name in the headlines like f IG radio
waves I've seen five g's probably tracks
that spider microchips I don't know I
don't know any of this stuff I just want
to live can I have a good time yeah food
make sure you know everyone gets gets
healthy don't worry about this just
chill man
cuz people are dying from this is that
crazy you know who uh-oh probably the
weirdest podcast we've ever done all of
our segways are super Catholic Chur talk
about a suicidal kid where I told him to
go die and I was like but he did it
though that's the moral of story or the
moral the story that was wrong and I
didn't know any by kid handles things
you know a kid isn't equipped for that
kind of [ __ ] I'm not ready for that
shooter [ __ ] people you know people used
to say really mean [ __ ] to everybody
when they're in high school like really
fun before I mean it's hard sometimes in
social media where you know we don't
have this capacity to forgive somebody
right and I have to remind myself of
that as well because sometimes when I
see stuff I get super angry and upset
but then I look at their a
they're like 12 years old 13 years old
and I'm like but they're so young they
still have time to better themselves
right I mean they should be reprimanded
for whatever they're doing or I can't
look at them like that's gonna be there
forever version of their selves right
now as an adult but somebody talks about
the depression whether or not I think
it's a joke or they're using it for
advantageous reasons I still probably
wouldn't tell them to go kill themselves
I would handle that situation a lot
better I'd be like listen guy you are
you are worth living yeah you're worth
living worth living do it to pet life is
good I really need to hear that you need
to live Nick and I want you to live when
you die I won't care yeah yeah but
that's boundaries you set your
boundaries you let them know how you
exactly feel about everything and that
makes it all are worth life and that is
important what do you say you are the
light weight good darkness is around us
and when you come here when he said
darkness II what can you save things
light is good how amazing of a pastor I
was if I was gonna kill myself and you
said that I would have not killed me
thank you
yeah and I'm gonna decide my life my
church kids also appreciated me pastor
so I feel like I'm gonna die today well
child when God planted the seed uh-huh
it grew Wow
nobody knew what the seed was but when
it grew it turned out to be a beanstalk
there was a giant upstairs and the pot
of gold
I kill yourself you don't get that pot
of gold it's almost like you raise your
hand you know he's like now close your
eyes swallow the whole documentary
because that's exactly how I do I go I
wasn't about my faceless like this oops
that is absolutely terrible make let me
ask you this scenario right now I am a
young child who is lost and I'm coming
to you for advice right all right my
name is is Peter supa dupa song alright
get out of my office I don't know how to
say your last name first
offensive I Philippines and I swam here
I gotta [ __ ] and I swam here Who am I to
you
huh you are a counselor alright and my
name is Peter malagant on is he wearing
the tank top and why do you look exactly
like that damn okay come on dance with
me and I'm just like yeah let's go
kumite dancing in a bar in that movie it
wasn't like a it was like a bar in blood
sport where he's dancing like this oh
yeah it was a kickboxer that was like it
wasn't it wasn't it was kick box there's
no dancing and yeah there's like just
two girls like dancing behind here
round-eyed yep we gotta go you're like
yes [ __ ] that guy what's it in Mack the
death patch I love that guy do anyways
here we go my name a Filipino child and
I'm asking you for advice I don't feel
life is worth it I just came here from
the Philippines two years ago and I'm
bullied you're gonna handle the
situation I'm helping you out dealing
with your child's emotional team
problems as a parent in the future here
we go and scene starts now hello mr.
Nick hello Peter
I don't be a light life is worth living
everybody makes fun of my accent and
they think I am stupid I opened up a box
upon sit there like it smells and I was
like put down my feelings are hurt don't
laugh at me you're just like their mr.
Nick tampons it is delicious and it's
one of my favorite noodles and pushes it
what should I do to handle this
situation because the other day they
punched me in my face and I said no and
I blocked with my face and it didn't
work
Peter right Peter Peter you have to you
you have you have to fight back and beat
the share these kids but how I just came
here and all I eat is rice and no meat I
have no power okay so this is what
you're gonna do you're gonna sign up for
kickboxing sessions with me and it's
$200 an hour hmm
tell your parents to venmo me it's that
Nick the ear and you can send those
payments every day
but I just told you I came from the
Philippines I have no money $150 an hour
and that's how we're gonna do this how
does that sound pewter you had the worst
okay let's uh yeah like how you gave
them a deal it's not bad 150 150 of mine
that's a you are the another counselor
and parent I'm the artist negotiation
it's called a it's a discount discount
offering that's what's called that kid
killed himself how do you feel about
that
just it's a third one this year that's
what that's what you are terrible
counselor I'm gonna give Pat you a
scenario I am a hot girl I am seven
years 11 mile all right
11 11 months you know and on top of that
time really and on top of that I am the
best friend to your daughter
Oh No so you have been seeing me around
I think I've said also this is not in
the United States this is Ukraine oh
I've seen these videos on internet
continue right and we're not gonna start
the scenario because this I really want
to see how he was gonna react to that
get the [ __ ] out here what are you doing
get the [ __ ] out here what do you mean
let me masturbate to your image later
get out of here BAM that's the 18th even
like if it wasn't my daughter's friend
Nadine is away young too young even 21
is like like [ __ ] ones like like you
know what it is though it's it's not
it's not the image of a person right
it's just how they behave that's so
[ __ ] annoying and disgusting ya know
because I'll go to these college shows
right and some you know some of my
friends would you already want to shoot
yourself they go like oh yes I do they
got a lot of young girls there also
exactly there are young girls yeah how
they speak and what they talk about
right now it's very sweet they're really
great but in terms of attraction
abso-fucking-lutely not they talk like
kids right here would it be to hook up
with a girl and she's like oh sorry my
mom's calling
yeah that's weird oh no because no and
so like when you as I get older like in
the YouTube space and we started doing
this shows I like being like it's kind
of like advice uncle yeah you given
there you be that advice about your
emotions chemical imbalances yeah
perfect when they start Conrad they're
like you know what I wish I had a guy
like you get the [ __ ] out of here you
sick [ __ ] yeah you slide with you [ __ ]
I'm emotion uncle all right get the [ __ ]
out of here emotional cool all right I'm
here to listen to your problems [ __ ]
what's wrong with you dude [ __ ] weird
but you realize they need help and
that's what it is you you guys yeah but
you suck as a counselor though you're a
bad dancer yup dude new scenario yours
Italian kid named Giuseppe alright just
set me is lower weight and all the kids
are calling him fat and they say that he
is not enough even though because he's
fat technically he is more than enough
here we go Giuseppe yeah counselor Nick
I came here to have this conversation
I don't know if I speak your English I
was attending this kidding you had a
spaghetti sauce has been chock-full of
accents I said a spaghetti said not a
waiter could do it I you gotta make a
pasta al dente and he said hey you a fat
boy you wouldn't know luck about a lot
of food how old are you Giuseppe this is
problematic at the [ __ ]
so how do I deal with the people are
calling it Giuseppe affero give me a
look at it give it like what would
Chancellor para SE I'm a Fed I keep a
telling a mom I'm not a fan and I'm not
feeling a hurt oh here's what I say I
say hey Giuseppe you know you what you
are a little fat and that's fine what
the [ __ ] and that's fine just just sign
up for my 30-day program it's $700 okay
so I'm a little fatter people calling me
fat sad like my program plugged my
program so Nick the ear just just have
you got to run around the block bro you
gotta [ __ ] put down the fork baby
I like that advice I like that you got a
move or losers go your loser I'm
definitely a bouncy son of a [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of my office forty year old
David happy things differently I didn't
know and look he's alive he's a pastor I
looked him in the eye - and you said it
probably like you're a loser you know
what you probably made his life better
because you're whole and I said you are
all losers and once you clean out those
ears he probably changes likely
imbalanced or not those year holes are
were problems yeah I felt terrible after
what I realized what I said to him I'm
and I'm glad that he chose to live well
I'm sure you made his life better you
know I want to look up a photo of him
and see how he's doing now I guarantee
you he has a six-pack and he has a photo
of me with knives in it what is it
hundred percent
he's a Muay Thai world champ he was he
was he was used to bike around the
neighborhood a lot so he had really
strong quads and I remembered probably
huge calves very huge calves and he had
a crush on the girl that I got with
later Danny hey [ __ ] guts yeah but
there was no way he was gonna get
all that your wife's [ __ ] life and I
sent him a little old monkey a pixelated
video I was like here you go keep
yourself alive
oops send them right over to hell yeah
so so far you guys have felt Giuseppe
and Peter no I think I think they're
gonna have another like the way you did
with what's the guy's name the Heather
your wife's problem mm-hmm what's the
name uh Nathon Noth on the phone we
probably would have a similar effect on
him and then we probably changed no I I
wholly regret doing that and I'm pretty
sure I [ __ ] him I bet he doesn't even
remember that
I'm sure I'm pretty sure he does I cuz I
remember and I start arrabal about it
till this day yeah he probably dislikes
all your videos oh that's okay the one
disliked on your videos 100% deserve it
but you know I think I think I think
times like that uh changes people for
the better but that's why they should
talk about this [ __ ] to high school
students so people like me don't make
that mistake and then minimize that
situation cuz I didn't know like I said
I didn't know that gay people didn't
have certain rights and I didn't know
that you think it was a serious thing
kids nowadays are getting better about
that stuff for sure because if you don't
know that you're considered a monster
yeah and they blast you on social media
but I think I think they they're getting
better about being aware of things but
they're also like there needs to be a
balance between that and still having
some thick skin you know you're like
they're losing thick skin that's the
problem like it's good to be aware [ __ ]
but it's also good to know like we can
[ __ ] around and joke around well because
I mean even when people talked about
bullying getting rid of it of a hundred
percent you're never gonna get rid of
bullying dude that's never it's built in
us as animals I feel like you see it in
the animal kingdom people get checked
and bullied all the time right we're
word animals just with a bigger [ __ ]
brain and a better thought process right
and bullying is going to happen people
hate it when somebody has something
that's different than you and I stick
out I yeah I think bullying is very not
that it's right I'm saying I stick out
all the time I just get bullied too but
that's just how people naturally
gravitate towards and in a way it kind
of like it's [ __ ] up but it kind of
serves a purpose it's like a bully
presents like a problem that you need to
deal with in some way shape or form you
can run from it or you can face it I
mean you it's not it like I said there's
varying degrees I'm not saying that's
called
that but like if you do stand up to a
bully like builds character
yeah sounds like you are kind of like
okay like the guy want to kick my ass
but like I didn't let him just have it
see what the [ __ ] was this advice to
Peter you piece of [ __ ] mr. pastor Pat
I've been bullied today what should I do
boy Peter are you the fat one or not I'm
a little that I'm really skinny mmm what
should I do this other guy his name is
Jared so he says I'm a loser for being
depressed so what am I supposed to do I
don't know man something good for you
well that is hurting might be anything
yeah yeah yeah you just join them you
know by doing David's team come join the
kids yeah you know I think it is
important to get bullied though because
it teaches you how to take [ __ ] huh I
got bullied most of my life especially
by this [ __ ] guy Wow
especially my adult life I don't bully
any kids you know like all the kids he's
come up to me and they sing that Spanish
song for about Chinese people Kolkata
yeah yeah that one they say Chino Chino
hop-ons Comic Con oh man abyss no that
means Chino Chino Chinese Chinese
hop-ons Japanese [ __ ] eat [ __ ] right no
no
Chino Chino hop-ons coma Kaakha Kaakha
Kaakha nervous oh yeah yo I said it
backwards eat [ __ ] you can't see me you
can't see me that's so interesting I
never had that in my era they were so
nice to me
they used to call me Matty : it was
really cool I'm like thank you what's
that mean it means handsome beautiful on
the inside
thank you for my first day of high
school and this is when most of my life
I've had giant years like my cauliflower
ear is a lot smaller now but my ear used
to be [ __ ] like this big on my head
and I just dropped the [ __ ]
headphones cuz I was like chill but at
the same time it's like my ears looked
huge compared to the rest of my head and
I was skinny at a [ __ ] big oil head
I'm still very skinny but I look like a
lollipop you know I mean that's that's
how big my head was in relation to the
rest of my body and my ears well with
good bullying then I just was like haha
I would laugh it off and I would try to
make jokes and eventually towards the
end I would learn how to like talk [ __ ]
back or learn eventually if something
really pissed me off I would be like
alright I'm gonna [ __ ] fight you
whatever but that's not but most of it
was just a scenario trying to become a
bully you're younger Nick so okay I know
this one quick story this is this is my
freshman year high school and this is an
example of how I you used to deal with
things these two dudes you come up to me
and I didn't know who they were and they
were like god damn look at this
[ __ ] ears and they pull up my
ears oh and they were grab my head like
God and they were just laughing like oh
my god this [ __ ] he is like
huge
nyeh they could not stop and they were
pulling my ears I didn't even know who
these people were dude and you let
people touch you like dog and I just was
like haha I know right
that's how I would have with a cage as a
14 year old I would have just started
swinging yeah but I didn't learn how to
deal with that until I got older right
first I would just like crack jokes and
[ __ ] but eventually I started getting
more comfortable where I would be like I
would eventually try to stand up for
myself like [ __ ] you dude
I would say [ __ ] like that but at the
time I didn't learn how to do that but
that's how would you deal with most of
my crap you're just be all cool with it
you know yeah but uh yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy I would just swing for my life I
don't give a [ __ ] Holly at that time I
just was like I just want I just want to
be friends with people because I didn't
really nobody at the time and that's how
I would handle well you would have been
known as a guy they started swinging on
[ __ ] when they touched you I
know but at the time I just didn't think
I would be able to yeah but that yeah
you're very small - I was this size and
that was like that was like my freshman
year but after that I didn't really have
any problems after my freshman year but
why'd you start at [ __ ] I putted hairs
oh no no no no no I would just I would
just try to be like
fun like I would try to like crack jokes
I'd be like ha you [ __ ] got big years
you'd be like ha ha you're [ __ ] on
financially your parents I never did
that I never did and then they would cry
and you would take it too far that's not
that cool I wouldn't have never done
that I did that so that's actually a
good note I'm gonna take that down
that's how you that's how you should
handle things stand up for yourself
don't be like me yeah you got to and
with the crazy honestly do you like
David his stories how he deals with uh
with bullies and stuff be like David
that's how you handle [ __ ] mm-hmm
stabbing people is not a stab yeah
blowing but you got to let people know
you got to set the boundary you do have
to do like though you can't do that I
mean if we're setting that I just wish I
didn't grow up in that situation like
it's kind of hard I think it's when
people now they look at the neighborhood
they're gonna live and they also think
about the schooling but no matter where
you go them just to argue against me
your kid's gonna get bullied somehow if
they're not a part of the clique that
doesn't get bullied right right which is
not a lot of kids something is going to
happen and you're gonna have to learn
how to teach your kids how to deal with
adversity I don't think that I dealt
with it too well because I just are
swinging on people but at the time but
that's the proper there's a time that's
like that is that's what you're supposed
to do back in like Christie generation
teachers didn't back me up
nobody backed me all right so it was
like I knew what you had to do yeah I
mean ice people still try to pump me but
it was so much less yeah after I just
started [ __ ] swinging on people
because I was a dweeb II fat kid with
glasses and now I'm a do we be fat adult
with no glasses so but I did set the
precedents up just don't [ __ ] touch
me at least yeah say whatever you want
but you know touching me though was
something I had to draw the line right
because it just I mean what where's it
then at that point right like you could
make the fat jokes or whatever I'll just
clown you back because now it's words
with words exactly and there's like
somebody else can come on top yeah but
the moment they put their hands on me is
where psych well this is where I have to
draw the line and my dad told me to he
always said if they touch you you can do
whatever you want
yeah well my favorite phrase as a kid
was put your hands on me and I just
wanted to hit them so bad but it would
always go from zero to 100 cuz they were
okay but you bit and I'm a cool
I would just start swinging yeah
remember in middle school I was like I
would get in a lot of fights in middle
school like I would like try to fight
him on the [ __ ] but then a high
school like sometimes I have this weird
thing where it still kind of happens now
we're in the moment when someone's like
trying to [ __ ] with me or something in
my head I'm just like ah they're just
yeah I'd be cool
and then in retrospect I realized like
oh they were kind of being dicks like
they were trying to [ __ ] with me or
they're trying to get a rise out of me
or something but at that time I remember
thinking like funny huh and I was like
oh I'm in on the joke - right like yeah
big-eared but the whole time I was like
oh wait they're [ __ ] there monkey
pick it off yet I had no idea it was
until after I realized like oh [ __ ]
there were being dicks but I think
either way I probably would have done
anything at that time but yeah you know
no wonder you couldn't give any advice
to frickin just set yeah dude cuz I cuz
in my head I knew I was like oh man I
was that guy I was him you know yeah but
you know worse counselors ever dude both
you do okay that's a fake scenario those
kids are fair you're the fat one or not
no I cou know a child named Kim Jong
buck comes in the store he comes and
said you have to be super nice to him
because his dad will murder you yeah
it's a my daddy so talking about kim
jeong-hoon that fool really faked his
own death now he's alive living his life
they put out an article well South Korea
did they're like you know life but
because people were saying that he was
dead
South Korea put up an article after
we're saying they know he's alive he
just went did the bubble of us oh yeah
so he ain't dead he's chillin they
thought that he he had a botched heart
surgery thing or some [ __ ] yeah like
where did they get that from but they
said South Korea confirmed that he was
alive yeah so he's he's good my muddly
good dude he's like he's our Korean
correspondent yo shout-out to I know
haven't seen the videos the video
[Laughter]
I feel like that's how he would play she
was so bad she was giving me a sex
alright now I'm gonna try that later so
Becky she's trying to work I just
screaming at her that's me that's trying
to work on my funny pig this is actually
my job
are you nuts
yeah getting mad at me cuz I was like
walking around the house and she's on
phone meetings like zoo meetings and
I'll just like I walk through the room
with my ass cheeks out I do that a lot
and then she'll get mad but it's like
whatever dude who cares I'm not let me
live I'm not in I'm not in the your
co-workers can't see me you know and on
that note guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
today we went over a lot of dumb dumb
dumb things number one let's just talk
about this bullying is not okay don't do
number two if you got a problem with gay
people you got a [ __ ] problem with me
alright let them [ __ ] live leave them
alone very odd to see that [ __ ] nowadays
and number three Nick is the worst
counselor I've ever met in my [ __ ]
life
you're being empathetic to your
classmates and your friends for their
issues and things such and so forth I am
inspired by [ __ ] I'm gonna I'm gonna
make your have to make a table for TIFF
right now oh that's a great novel a
tearful TIFF a table for teeth a
lifetime like series yeah that's gonna
be the boring is lifetime [ __ ] series
made you a table movie and see the movie
is [ __ ] Nick coming in and I got
something to talk to you about Pat can
you make this tape comment if you've
been making tables but you haven't made
one for tiff what the [ __ ]
intro [ __ ] dramatic music yeah hey
making this [ __ ] apple pie that you
asked alright you'll [ __ ] the apple pie
make this table for TIFF TIFF comes in
she walks in don't fight over me guys
we're not [ __ ] fighting over you
get out of your [ __ ] and then Pat mix
it well and see Nancy bond resolution
direct fiendin fi in yes lower case that
lowercase cursive
tighten the Jesus pray paw stuck my dick
the genius brain podcast uh why did I
say suck my dick my head was by your
dick
I know but they can't hear that I can
hear that they this episode is brought
to you by Skillshare Holy Spirit the
Holy Spirit guys let it fill your mouth
you can catch us on Spotify iTunes
everywhere else where can they find you
guys you could find me on Instagram and
Nick the ear and you could look for our
podcast big mad on YouTube and with a
cream cheese apples podcasts and such
and so forth stuff like that
yeah and me on Instagram as well what
making [ __ ] sourdough bread baby
what's your handle dude hat-trick TDOT
Riley and also perfect segment one of
the Gees of the big man and one of the
one of the Gees in big mad alice is not
here today because he was not invited we
only got three bikes
but we'll see you all next time [ __ ]
big baby pee